on les connaît surtout pour la collecte
de sang mais ma québec a aussi besoin de
mamans pour participer à la banque
publique de lait maternel qui est en
forte demande auprès des grands
prématurés ce lait j'en discute avec
laurent paul ménard les porte parole
d'héma québec monsieur ménard ou un
manteau alors ce lait maternel que l'on
recueille est destiné donc où je disais
aux bébés prématurés
c'est très important c'est vrai pour la
santé du pont en fait ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que dans à peu près 30%
une naissance sur trois deux grands
prématurés au québec
la maman n'est pas en mesure d'arrêter
son enfant et le lait d'origine humaine
a des vertus qui ont été démontrées
surtout au niveau préventif pour une
maladie de bien précises au niveau du
système digestif des très grands progrès
doit se contenter de l'est
une formule de l'aide mais on peut
toujours se rabattre sur cette solution
que ce qui a été démontré c'est la
raison pour laquelle héma québec avait
été approché à la base pour débuter
cette activité d' assez que le led
d'origine humaine aurait des propriétés
préventives au niveau de l'antérieur
colite nécrosante c'est un beau gros
terme non mais c'est une maladie qui
touche le système digestif des grands
prématurés donc à titre préventif
l'utilisation du ddt est d'origine
humaine est tout à fait indiqué bon il
n'y a pas de pénurie nécessairement de
l'aisne cependant dit combien de
donneuses avez vous besoin par année là
pour satisfaire aux besoins en fait le
programme atteint un peu son attitude de
croisière présentement héma québec comme
le lait maternel peut être une fois
transformé qualifie il peut être
congelés et conservés pour une période
d'un an
et donc on utilise en quelque sorte la
réserve qui a été constituée au fil des
ans maintenant la demande est
grandissante parce qu'on a de plus en
plus de centres hospitaliers partenaires
qui commande de se dé là et on doit
passer de d'environ 500 donneurs sa
1000e donneuse
sur une base constante parce que vous
voyez qu avec la demande grandissante
vous réussirez pas à répondre à la
demande encore très longtemps le siaap à
une augmentation du nombre de donneurs
vous avez combien soit votre objectif
annuel en termes de litres en terme de
limites on parle de 4 mais dit on parle
de 40 milles de rose si on veut parce
que des doses de lait maternel sont
produites en bouteille de 100
millilitres
et on parle donc de 48 12 et donc
quarante mille doses que vous avez
besoin
comment ça fonctionne est ce qu'il est
bon pour ce qui est des donneuses qui
vont nous écouter aujourd'hui des
donneurs potentiels qui voudraient
pouvoir donner du lait comment ça
fonctionne on sera ou en fait tout seul
au québec est tout à fait conscient que
la contribution des mamans elle est
quand même extrêmement importantes elles
ont déjà un jeune enfant et donc
nous
facilitant le plus possible de devenir
jonque première démarche c'est d'aller
tout simplement sur le site web d'héma
québec on va à la section du des
donneuses de lait maternel et ont rempli
un questionnaire par la suite une
infirmière entrer en communication avec
les mamans et à partir de là il va y
avoir des les autres éléments de
qualification mais c'est somme toute
assez simple pour pour une maman au
niveau de l'inscription s'entend parce
que c'est sûr que la participation aux
programmes
ça demande un investissement il faut que
la maman aussi soit non fumeuse qu'elle
est un surplus de lait maternel est
fourni pour son propre enfant et c'est
tout à fait normal qu'on adore fumeurs
d'avoir un surplus de lait maternel
conditions résider dans une des régions
où le programme est à faire donc on
parle essentiellement le des grandes
régions de québec de montréal également
du côté de gatineau saguenay et gatineau
saguenay sherbrooke
est-ce que c'est plus difficile de
trouver des donneurs de l'est que par
exemple des donneurs de sang parce que
ça que les donneuses de l'est s'est
restreint dans le temps les femmes de
progrès avis vous avez entièrement
raison le défi là c'est que les mamans
peuvent donner du lait tant et aussi
longtemps que leur enfant ne pas
atteindre l'âge de 12 mois
aussitôt que l'enfant atteint l'âge de
12 mois elles cèdent leur place et donc
nous sommes dans une dynamique de
recrutement constant donc c'est le défi
au niveau de la gestion d'une telle
banque au niveau des donneurs de sang on
peut avoir des donneurs qui ont une
belle carrière qui est sur plusieurs
années dans le cas des mamans
c'est en moyenne à peu près six mois la
participation des des donneurs
qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce lait bon
bien sûr 6 le lait pour tout de suite
comme ça de données vous disiez qui
était potentiellement qu'on fait le
congé dans certains cas maison est
traité sur l apport aux études afe tout
à fait donc le lait est reçu à un mât
québec qui voyait avoir d'abord des
vérification au niveau de la
contamination bactérienne par la suite
ça va être foulé et donc on va le sous
le thème une pasteurisation pour faire
un autre test par la suite et c'est
congelés tout ça dans le but d'aider ces
petit poupon née de façon prématurée on
a de plus en plus au québec la demande
vous disiez de plus en plus grande
alors les gens qui voudraient donner les
femmes qui voudraient donner on a
simplement s'informer jeu du côté des
mots québec
elle leur en parle maintenant merci
beaucoup d'erreurs au mail adresse
numéro de téléphone à l'écran madame
messieurs si vous êtes intéressés donc à
donner du lait merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui
merci à vous